えーと 大体どこら辺までですか
このくっきりとはいってないんですね
そこでこの前 心っていうのは何かを認識することを心であって
我々に認識する窓口チャンネルは 6つありますね
その 6つから入る情報を知るということになってるんですね
6つは有名な眼耳鼻舌身意というもので
そこから情報入る 入る情報は認識する
で まあ眼耳鼻舌身という目耳鼻という 5つは一応物体であって体なんですね
で 体と言ったっても 体が何もできるわけじゃない
ただの物体だから そこで体にはこのいわゆる命根という
この何か生きてるという機能があるんですね
で そこで普通に我々は目という場合は
私たちが目という物体だけではなくて
目で知るという 目で見るという
そのことも頭にあるんですね
私の目ですよと言ったら
ただの目玉を考えてるわけじゃないんです
お医者さんがそう考えるかもしれませんだけど
普通だったら見える機能を考えてるんです
ですから アビダンマは仏教の立場から言えば
我々は目と言った途端
そこにナーマとルーパ両方我々は混ぜて混ぜて目と言うんですね
耳と言ってて同じことで
で そこで私の心ですよという場合は
人間がちょっと混乱するんですね
なぜかというと 目と言ったらつかめる物体があるんですね
目という そこで我々はナーマとルーパを混ぜて
一般的に俗世間で目と言うんですね
言ったらみんななんかあれ
これはただの物体じゃないんだと
何かもっとわからない何かあると感じてるんですね
そのわからない何かあるんだと感じているところは心なんですね
ナーマなんですね 耳と言ったっても
ただの耳じゃないんだと
ただの耳だったらお人形さんの耳も耳ですからね
で 私の目と言っちゃうと
聞く働きある聞く機能
ですから聴覚もそこに我々の感情で入ってるんですね
それは人間の感情なんですね
で 感情ですけど そこに確実に目という色
物質もあって 聴覚という心もそこにあって
そのまとめてワンセットで人間が耳と言うんです
ですから 人間の問題がこのあまり分析しないんですね
適当に分析する 目では聞こえるんだ
目では見えるんだとか
それだけの分析であって
分析して理解しようとするならば
とことん徹底的に ギリギリまでもう二度と分析できないところまで分析しなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 初期仏教はその態度をとるんですね
とことん分析して 分析して
どこまでも分析してみると
だから分析するということがこのなんか悪いことじゃないんです
分析する人こそ このものの関連性
どのようにものが一緒になって行動するかと
どのようにこの新しい現象が現れるかっていうことがわかるんですね
これとこれを混ぜたところでこういうことになりますよと
例えば人が醤油の味はまるっきり知らないんだったら
塩の味まるっきり知らないんだったら
砂糖の味まるっきり知らないんだったら
どうやってそれを合わせて美味しい味作るんですかね
別々に知ってるんだから
もうちょっと塩を入れた方がいい
もうちょっとお塩を入れた方がいい
もうちょっと砂糖を入れた方がいいとわかるでしょうに
そうするとこの味の場合は
我々はこの各々の味が知っている
知ってるんだから組み合わせができるようになるんですね
ですから この分析するならばとことん分析するということは必要なんです
大雑把に分析しないで
そういうことで 一般の社会では
目といえばもうナールの両方混ぜて目ですよという
私ですよと言った途端
みんなこの物体的な体と自分の心をまとめて私ですよと言うんですね
そこでナーマ働きと心の働きとルーパの働き
2つの流れがありますよとは知らないんですね
ですから それを知ることは大変大事なことなんです
真理するためには なぜ人間が世の中でこの哲学的に宗教的に間違っているかと
間違っているというのはちょっとした批判的な言葉なんですけど
なぜ人間が真理に悟ってないかというと
真理を知らないんだからなんですね
なぜ知らないかというと
そういう風にナームループごちゃ混ぜで皆様考えているんですね
目耳鼻あると言ったらわかるんだけど
そこにナームとループあると言ったらざっくりわからなくなっちゃう
例えばヨーロッパでは 5本しか考えてないんですね
この眼耳鼻舌身の眼耳鼻舌身だけしか考えてないんですね
ヨーロッパ人に第 6感というのは何か超越した能力なんですね
でもすでに人間に第 6感
第6まで感覚機能あるんですけど
ヨーロッパ人も人間だから
我々も人間だから 当たり前で思い存分妄想したり考えたりしたりしているでしょうに
我々よりもものすごいくだらないことを考えてるんだから
その人々は 神様はいるんですか？ないんですか？ああだこうだとか
人生はどうですか 楽しいですか？苦しいですか？とかね
ほとんどの哲学生まれたのはまたヨーロッパの方だから
その人が自分の頭で考えてるんですね
でもそれは第6番目の感覚器官だと発見しないんですね
なぜかというと この分析することをとことんやってないんですね
日本文化ではヨーロッパ人がよく分析するんだと
我々はあまり分析しないんですよとまとめてみるんだと
まあ言いたがってるでしょうね
でも私が言いたいんですね
ヨーロッパ人もろくに分析しないんだと
大ざっぱですよと それぐらい大ざっぱな分析は日本でもありますからですよね
分析しなきゃ物事を立てないでしょうに
例えば生け花とかね 花立てることも分析しなきゃできないもんなんです
花瓶の働き  1本1本の花の働き
1本の 1枚の葉の働き
そういうのは頭の中である程度で
この花はこうすればこう見える
こうすればこう見えるという知識があって
そこで合わせるんですね
それで花が生けたことになっちゃうんですね
ですから いくらなんでも分析する能力は必要なんですね
分析する人が組み合わせも知ってるんです
例えば一旦植えた花でも
他の流派の人が来たら
いえ こんな感じじゃなくて違う感じ出したいなと思ったら
同じ花と同じ花瓶 ちょっと組み合わせて違う作品作るでしょうに
作られるでしょうに 簡単に
それも結局は分析能力なんです
ですから まあ大ざっぱな分析では
人間誰でもやってることなんですね
日本人がやらないっていうのはおかしいでしょうし
中国人やらないってことはおかしいですよ
誰でもやってるんです
ヨーロッパ人もやってるんです
大ざっぱなところは で
問題はこの究極的なところまで
せっかく分析していいものできるんだったらと
こと分析してみますということをやらないだけ
それでヨーロッパの哲学の場合は
思想の体系 思想体系の場合は
目耳鼻といったら具体的に感覚器官
これルーパですか ルーパとナーマが見つかっちゃうんですね
まとめて区別はできないんだけど
そこで心というものはルーパとして見つからないんですね
目はこれですよと言えますけど
取り出して見せることもできますけど
舌はこれは人の舌ですよと
切断死でもこれ舌ですよと言えますけど
そこでルーパがありまして
ナーマの働きがある 心の働きがある
じゃあこれは心ですよという何か体の中に何か器官がないんですね
だから五根に終わってしまうんですね
ですから ヨーロッパ哲学はやっぱり物理学の次元はなかなか超えてないし
それでそれでも心の働きっていうのは抑えられないもの
体より巨大な働き 膨大な働きをしているのは心なんですね
人間がものを見てみてよくわかるわけじゃないんです
耳で聞いてよくわかるわけじゃないんです
目で見たものを 耳で聞いたものを
頭の中でいろんなプロセスを経て
いろんな組み合わせをして
そこで知識っていうものを作るでしょうに
それで人間の苦しみというのは
ただ寒いんだから苦しい
消化不良だから苦しいとか
車にぶつかったんだから苦しいという苦しみだけじゃなくて
なんのことなく苦しい人々もいるんですね
なんか自信がないとか
なぜ自信がない いえ 車にぶつかったんだから自信がないよ
そういう具体的なことじゃないんですね
なぜ頭の自信があなたに自信がないんですか？と聞いたら
実は今日朝ごはん食べなかった
だから自信がないんだと
そういうふうに言うならば
具体的でわかりやすいんだけど
そうわからないでしょう
なんか自分に自信がない
自分が対人関係はできない
人を見るのは怖いとかね
そういう精神的な病気が確実にあるでしょうに
それは目から生まれた病気か耳から生まれた病気かと
ヨーロッパ人にわからなくなっちゃうでしょうね
ヨーロッパ人でもそれですって
西洋思想体系でわからないでしょうね
そうすると やっとゆっくりゆっくり心理学というものはもう発展し始めたんですね
それでも本流というか
科学体系から外れ外れているんですね
これは科学ではありませんと
おそらく哲学でしょうと
言っても哲学者も いえ
あんた方はちょっとあっち行けと
あんた方言ってることはちょっとおかしい
おかしいじゃなくて 我々の研究もしやったから
ちょっと違いますから
あっち行きなさいと 言ったら
心理学研究者というのは自分たちが具体的な例を出したり
実例を見て考えているんだから
科学のようなんですね
で 科学者の方に入ると
ちょっと待ってください
あんた方は具体的な研究をしているわけじゃないんだから
こっち来るなという状態で
もう科学にも入らなくて
哲学にも入らなくて 中途半端な恍惚状態で心理学を発展してきたんですね
それでやっぱり心の悩み
病気っていうのは は何と言いますか
体に影響あるんですよという証拠が出始めたら
医学分野で心理学のところも一応講義として入ってしまったんだけどね
いまだにしっかりした科学として認めてないんですね
科学は物理学であると決まってるんですから
で 私は言いたがっているのは
この心の働きっていうのは巨大なもので抑えられないもの
人間  1時間仕事をしたら
この 1時間の中で体にした仕事と心でした仕事を分けちゃうと
もう心でも 1時間中 40分以上心で仕事しているんですね
心で考えて体動かすのはほんの僅かなんですね
ですから心っていうのは確実にある
でも ナーマのことまじで知る人々にとっては
ナーマだけを知ることは不可能になっちゃったんですね
ナーマにルーパがついてこなきゃもうわからないんです
ですから 仏教では眼耳鼻舌身意と普通に人間にどんな人間にも六根ありますとと言ってるんです
ベースに大したことじゃなくて
ごく普通の常識として六根がありますよと言ってるんです
そこで目耳鼻といったら
物体を通る 物体を媒体するというかね
して ものは知る 心だったら別に物体を媒体する必要はないと
心は自分で直接知ることできるんですから
いわゆる何の情報もなくても
我々のは過去を思い出すことはできるし
いくらでも頭を回転させて思考を働かすことを
わかりやすく言えば妄想することはベースに何の原因もなくできるでしょうに
こういうことを妄想しようと思っちゃえばいくらでもできるんです
別に情報はいりません
例えば花を見て この花を人間の顔として考えましょうと思ったらできるでしょうに
こちらが耳目があって
こちらが鼻があって ここら辺口ですよと
具体的に情報必要だったらそれはできませんでしょうし
だから確実に顔のように見える花でないと川を想像することはできないんです
でも人間にはもう顔の川の顔のように見えなくても
どんな花を見てでもそちらに一つの人の顔をイメージすることができる
ですから 心には別に情報がなくても自分勝手に行動できる
で ですからポイントは眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つのチャンネルがあるといっても
その心が知ってるんです
いわゆる意ですか 心ですか
心が目で見ている 心が耳で聞いている
心が舌で味わっている
心が鼻で香りを嗅いでいる
心が体で観測を感じている
心が心で物事を考えたり知ったりするという
ですから 心は 5つの場所で物体を媒体とする
一つの場所で自分だけで知るということをする
そこは一応この基本的に理解してほしい
このアビダンマのこの言葉とかね
分析よりはアビダンマの狙いはそこにあるんです
それは誰もなかなか教えてくれないんです
それはこの仏教の哲学なんですね
で 皆様に目に触れるのはもう哲学に使ったこの道具だけなんです
ラベリングだけなんです
言葉だけ その言葉を使ってどのような世界観
どのような人間観 どのような生き方があるかと知ることが一番大事なことなんですね
それから自分の国では
この仏教 一般的な研究よりは仏教哲学を研究した方がいいという
経典の研究とかね もうすでに100年前にほとんどやりましたから
もうやらなくてもいいと
いまだに日本の大学ではないんですね
仏教哲学という風に見る
いまだに基本研究ばっかりやってますけど
で ですから アビダンマそのものはラベリングラベリングして
これは 5つあります これは16あります
これは18あります とかね
で それも必要ですけど
その中でそんな風に分けて分けて何を言おうとしているでしょうかと
どのような世界観でしょうか
どのような人間観でしょうかと
そこをやっぱり知るべきところで
で それからこの この前の説明なんですけど
あの目と耳と鼻と口と舌と体の場合は
情報っていうのは具体的な物質を体にぶつかることなんですね
いわゆるある物質とある物質がぶつかっちゃうんですね
ぶつかったところでどうせ反応が起こるでしょうね
[笑い]あるものともう一つのものがぶつかったら
何らかの反応は確実に起こるはずなんです
何の反応もないとは言えません
そのどんな反応かと心が知るんです
そこで目にぶつかる物質は
まあアビダンマで言えば光とは言ってないんだから形と
もっと厳密に言えばものの色だと
ものの色と言った途端
科学的な知識を使うと
もう光になってしまっちゃうんですね
色っていうのは光ですから
ですから そのものが目にぶつかっちゃうんです
ぶつかるためには やっぱりまあ動いてないとぶつからないんですね
止まってたらぶつからないんですね
そこで音という物質があって
それはもう体中ぶつかりますけど
耳にもぶつかっちゃうんですね
当たっちゃうんですね
当たったら 体に音が当たったら体は反応しますよ
でも耳に当たったら耳が反応する
耳に反応したものは 我々は音として心が
我々はではなくて 心が音として聴覚として認識する
そこで体に触れる音を我々どのように認識します？この音楽なんかね
大きな音で聴くと 低音なんかはもう耳よりはお腹に触れちゃうんですね
体にもうほとんどお腹と言ったっても
体の水分を体の中に入っている水分を振動させちゃう
そうするとそれは音じゃないんですね
体でなんかお腹まで響くんだよと
体に体まで響くんだよと言うんです
それは音ではありません
それは体に触れたことだ
体は感覚で知っている
それで体の中に入っている水分ですか
液体ですか その水分に簡単に音が吸収されて振動しちゃうんですね
そこで触れるなと 例えば耳に聞こえない音でも知りたければどうすればいいんですか
手に触ればいいんです
私は普通やりますからね
まあいろんな店なんかね
いろんなこのもう音楽機械というよりはね
ステレオとかいっぱい出して
全部もうデモンストレーションやってるんですね
だからどんな機械 どんな音を出しているか分からないんですね
あ これはきれいな音だと
そんな音だと この機械どういうこと？全部電気つけてるんです
私はやるのを触ってみるんです
あ 触ったらここは振動出してないんだから
これはこの振動はこの音だとわかるんです
その耳ではなくて 耳のまず耳で決めたんだから
この音はそんな音だからどんな機械かと知りたくなる
で 区別できなくなっちゃうんですね
4つ  5つぐらい並んでるんだから
で 触ってみると 機械触ったら手に知ってるんですね
あ このこの音だと その場合は体の感覚なんです
それは音じゃないんですね
で そういうことで 眼耳鼻舌身の場合は何が必要かというと
何か物質 何かルーパが我々のその適切なチャンネルにぶつかってる
触れるということは必要なんです
触れたらどうせ反応が起こる
それは仏教ではファッサですか
触という専門用語で使ってるんですね
それは一応心性の方に入れてるんですね
心の働きとして その反応は心で受けますから
物質的なファッサ 触は使ってないんです
物質的な反応がチースリカーフだから
それは別にまたダブりますから使ってない
その代わりに心に生まれる
この 例えば人が私の体を触ったとする
あるいは野球球が流れてきて
私の体に触れたとする
そうすると具体的に体にも反応を起こすんですよ
そこら辺ね 青くなったりとか
あるいはもう怪我するとかね
そういう具体的な反応はあるんだけど
それを見れば怪我してるんだと分かりますけど
で その怪我であろうか
青くなることであろうか
それはチースリカーフそのものだから
別に反応についてルーパのレベルで喋る必要はないと
で その反応を心で受けるんですから
その心で受ける分はファッサという触ということが考えていて
触自体は経一切身性に入ってるんですね
なぜならば認識するためには触でなければ
触なしには認識はしない
ファッサなしには認識はあり得ません
じゃあそれでまあ常に考えられるのはこういうことなんですね
で 仏教でいうルーパというものは
一つの流れるものだから
止まってたら触れませんから
ぶつかるためにはどちらかが動いていなきゃダメなんですね
ですから 色のレベルで
ルーパのレベルで すべてのルーパが瞬間瞬間生滅変化という波として動いているんです
止まっていない じゃあ私の体は止まってるかと
止まってないんです 歩く時だけ動いてるんですかね
そうじゃないんです 私はいろんな鎖で
もう部屋に上も東西南北も四方八方からつなげておいたんだと
そうすると私の体は動けませんでしょうに
それでも体は動いてるでしょ
もし十年そういう風に止まった状態いたらどうなるんだ
この体が 十年年取ったって
それなりに変化して 運動できなかったんだから
どんどん体が小さくなったりとかね
体全く動かないで十年間いたならば
いくらご飯食べても体は小さくなるでしょう
ということは 体の物質はどんどんどんどん流れて出ていくということなんです
だから物質は止まってないんです
私たちに分かりやすいのは物質の移動だけ
この移動 我々考えてる移動は違うんですね
我々考えてる移動っていうのは
ある個体がある場所から違う場所へ動くことなんですね
その移動ではなくて ダイナミズムは仏教で考えていることなんですね
物質時代は自体はずっとどんな物質であろうとも
ずっと動いているんだと
それは普通にお釈迦様の言葉だったら無常という言葉にありますし
アビダルマになっちゃうと生住滅の波として考えているんですね
だから無常ということはアニッチャというね
停止していない 常に在らずと
一箇所に止まって停止状態ではイスタティックではないんだと
ダイナミックだと ということをお釈迦様は簡単な言葉で
それはもっと美しい言葉なんですけど
で 分かりやすく言ってるんですね
それアビダルマでさらに分析して
生住滅にしているんですね
そこで物質が動いているんだから
我々の体に触れると で
そこで物質の流れ どれぐらいの振動で動くかというと
やっぱりそれもセツナ
時間はセツナということで考えているんですね
セツナの時間は秒ではなかなか計算できませんし
まあ論理的には計算できますけど
実際にセツナの時間を測ってみて
それは一秒何分の1かとは
もう計算するのは具体的には不可能ですから
あまり誰も分析してないんですけど
一応もうミャンマーの注釈書になっちゃうと
指をこうやって鳴らす時間の何分の1でしたっけ？こっち書いてあったんだから
ん？なんかそこら辺どこかで書いてあったんだけどね
で そういうのもまあそのまま正しいわけじゃなくて
まあただ例えで速いでしょうって言ってることだけなんですね
そんなに厳密に計算できるわけじゃないんだからね
まあそれだったらサーリプッタ尊者かお釈迦様か
それをものすごい巨大な智慧の人
方々が言ってくれなきゃダメでしょうし
ですから まあそこら辺はまあ適当に速いと
で このセッツナということも心が一番速い
心が一回転する時間はワンセッツナですね
一セッツナですね チッタッカナと読むんですね
そこで物質は一回転する時間は十七セッツナになってるんですね
で そこでこれから目のことを言いますけど
目に触れる何か光か色か形があるとする
目にぶつかったそのものはどれぐらい時間いるかというと
十七セッツナ生きてるんですね
一応は そこで十七セッツナはアビダンマで伝統的なチャートありますから
一応時間を軸を書いてこれぐらいにするんですね
一応時間はこれを十七セッツナだと十七に分けると
で それは一つのこの物質がこの瞬間に生まれて
生まれていて 生まれていて
この瞬間でその物質が死んでしまったと
そこで心はの一つの心の寿命は一セッツナだから
それと心比べてみると心がこうやって短いんですね
これ適当 まあいいか まあいいです
で 心のセッツナで計算すると
この まあ例えば花でも何でもいいんだけど
で 人が花を見ようとした
見た瞬間にその花が 花の物質が生まれてるんだから
その物質はこれぐらいの時間が残ってるんですね
その間は心は十七回死んでなくなって
新しい心が生まれてるんですね
で どんな言葉で書けばいいんですかね
パーリ語だったら全部覚えてますけど
どうしよう こちらに入ってないかな
[紙をめくる音]で どんな言葉で書くでしょうかね
で あの じゃあこれは目で見えるものだから
これは目にする チャックにします
パーリ語で書けば で 目にものが入る
で 人間の心は何も認識していない場合はウブンシンでいるんですね
はっきりした認識は何もしていない
ウブンシンというこの存在を生き続いているんですね
ですから この色が ルーパがここで物質が生まれたんだけど
それ目に触れるんだけど
こちらでこのウブンシンなんですね
あるのは ですからウブンシンであって
ここはどのように書くんだろう
まあまずはパーリ語で書いて
あとで日本語で書いてもらいます
こっちはバワンガチットと書くんですね
で バワン ウブンシンがありまして
で ウブンシンの状態っていうのは
心は自分の目に何か触れたっていうことはまだ知らない
でも触れたことは触れたんですけどね
そこで次の心にも同じもの触れるんですね
二回目に触れると このウブンシンが少々弱くなるんですね
少々弱くなるんですね
それはパーリ仏教ではバワンガチャルナと言うんですね
まあ見えないかもしれませんけども
字が小さすぎて で このウブンシンが少々弱くなる
そこで弱いウブンシンが死んじゃうんです
ワンセッスナ取ったら
一セッスナ過ぎたら 死んだところで次の
の有分身が生まれるんですね
次のパーリ語でバヴァングパッチェーダと言うんです
ウパッチェーダ でもそれも有分身なんです
一番目の有分身ではもう完全には寝ている状態
二番目はなんとなく弱くなり始めた状態
三番目はもう結構この有分身
寝ている心がもう弱くなっちゃったんです
もう寝ていられない 何か触れているんです
痒い 目には何か物質触れてるんです
それ反応でなんか痒いみたいな状態になっていて
そこで心の心が覚めるんですね
有分身状態から 覚めるんだから
この四番目のセッツナでパンチャドゥーラワッジャという心が生まれるんですね
それで日本語で五門陰転と言うんですね
で 次の一連で その五門陰転というのは特別な目が覚めたという状態なんですね
目が覚めたのはなぜかというと
目に何か情報触れてるんですね
何か目にザーザーとぶつかってるんですよ
瞬間のことなんですけど
目にぶつかっちゃったんだから
心が目が覚めたと だから目に触れると体に触れると耳に触れると鼻に触れると舌に触れると物質が触れるんですね
物質が触れたんだから
どうせ五門の問題なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身のどこかに触れたんだと
そこでそのどこに触れたかなと
この触れた場所に心が移動しなくちゃいけない
この痒い場所に この痒い場所に移動する心にパンチャドゥーラワッジャナあるいは日本語で五門陰転
と言うんです じゃあもう一つ
あの説明は戻ります で
パンチャドゥーラワッジャナっていうのは覚めた心
もう心は寝ていない そこでなんでここにこの有分身有分身有分身と書かないで
バヴァングバヴァングバヴァングと書かないで違う言葉使っているかというと
もうそんなに意味の差がない
大した意味のことじゃないんです
一応いきなり瞬時に目が覚めないということなんですね
いわゆる心にはいきなり大胆な変化は起こりません
波ですから ゆっくり上がったらゆっくり下がらなくちゃいけない
下がってすぐ頂点に上がるということがなくて
下がったところからじわじわと上がらなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この有分身がものすごい徹底的に寝ている状態で
次の瞬間でパッと目が覚めたということはないんです
有分身自体がどんどん弱くなると
ですから バヴァングチャラナっていうのは
バヴァングというのは有分
チャラナっていうのは揺れるという意味なんですね
有分が揺れると 二番目
三番目バヴァングパッチェーダっていうのは有分が切れるという
止まる 断つ 切れるという意味なんですね
でもその三つも有分身なんですね
何の問題もなく 有分身ですけど
一番目の有分身は本格的に寝ていて
二番目はもうちょっと揺れて
三番目はもうあまりにも揺れすぎて
次にはもう有分身ではできないんです
という状態 ですから 四番目はもう有分身はいません
四番目にこの見る人にある心にはパンチャドゥーラワッジャナ
あるいは五門陰転ということを言うんです
タカハシさん これ日本語で書きますかね
はい  アティットバヴァングは私は書いてない
これがカなんですけどね
こちらはアティットと書いてあるけど
これはカと  ゼロの次にくるのがカと
そうでしょ だから  これで五門書いて